was there a moment where you're like
guys we're like
rock stars we did it
yeah when did it hit you that you're
like this is [ __ ]
massive i guess you know what when
[ __ ] people start
you know and people start [ __ ] you
know
hating on you like the pmrc yeah like
when as soon as you
that's exactly it dude as soon as
[ __ ] like
you know you're you're pissing somebody
off you know you're doing something
right right yeah
so right when that happens or when you
start getting recognized in public or
you know you school you start to realize
oh whoa man shit's different
this is very different people are asking
for you to tattoo their name on them
yeah you're like dude no no mom was like
dude are you sure
that you want motley crew or or my name
or whatever it is
think about go like fast fast forward
like when you're like 75 or 80 are you
still gonna be like [ __ ] yeah
if yes then go nuts yeah do it i don't
like
i don't like people getting my name or
my face tattooed over
there that's strange yeah people will
say like oh do you tattoo your autograph
on me and i go nah you don't want my
autograph let me tattoo your name on
your butt like i have it you know yeah
my butt cheek says your name that way
it's kind of like signature stevo but
like it's kind of funny too it's more
worth it yeah but uh uh dude so
like you were 17 when when motley crue
formed so then that was like 81 two
years like you're only you're only 19
years old when you're opening for ozzy
and [ __ ] playing arenas and
and like holy [ __ ] shout out the devil
yeah i mentioned the pmrc which was the
parents
music resource center there was like in
the 1980s
a concerted [ __ ] effort to like
censor it was a real first first
amendment issue
like like wait a second these [ __ ]
heavy metal bands
are satanists you know the original
album
title for shout out the devil and that's
the album that blew up motley crew
it was originally called shout with the
devil
which is like pro satan like come on
we're [ __ ] on satan's team
shout with them join satan's club and
that was like okay there was
the blowback came back from i guess
electoral records they were like yo dude
you can't call a show
yeah and so they said okay we'll call it
shout at the devil
implying that we're somehow like angry
at the devil and we'll say like
whoever it is that [ __ ] you know
represents evil to you man if it's your
[ __ ]
if it's your boss if it's the cops
probably probably nikki's you know nikki
was like
it's pretty smart you know like let's
just make this like about like
shouting at any sort of like resistance
any opposition anybody's [ __ ] with
you don't take it you shout at the devil
shout at the devil
yeah and it was just genius because like
there was this climate
at the time that was just so like they
called it the satanic panic
and like there was the whole thing with
ozzy on his first album he had a song
called suicide
solution which was clearly about alcohol
like like in chemistry a solution is a
liquid
and all this song was saying is that
alcohol is just a slow way of killing
yourself
but some [ __ ] kid was listening to
ozzy's record had it on the record
player with his headphones on
and [ __ ] shot his brains out the kid
committed suicide
and they found his body with his
headphones on connected to the [ __ ]
record player and the [ __ ] record
player says ozzy osbourne
suicide solution so there was this huge
lawsuit against ozzie
and [ __ ] he walks in he's like you
[ __ ] dummies
it's about alcohol and they're like okay
cool dismissed
[ __ ] crazy man yeah
dude